that men on Batman let's jump into that
Justice League trailer real quick
features of it
moments open strong I thought smart too
you can tell the times we live in it
opens all Wonder Woman yes it does
totally so much so that if you're like
not somebody to follow [ __ ] this [ __ ]
closely a bit like oh they made a sequel
already
it was [ __ ] fast you know I know that
thing everybody likes a lot let's just
do that
here's [ __ ] more of it so it starts
with her which is great not a little
button joke of her in the museum and
should I go would you do Diana she's
like [ __ ] up people but and then they
jump into the credits and one of the
first images you see is they acknowledge
the world without a Superman and they
talk about Batman's a Batman or the bat
of Gotham whatever they're calling them
not being around and they say something
like crime has run rampant in the world
like world crime [ __ ] like that or
sometimes like ooh that sounds metal and
so then they start slowly showing you
like you know a little we saw one piece
before a Bruce Wayne talking to Diana
and stuff and her gone like I thought
the Age of Heroes was dead he says it
has to come back or whatever and then
you see the team what's insanely
impressive in this trailer first one we
saw
looks like Aquaman is going to be a good
time this trailer looks like ho [ __ ]
this is the Aquaman movie like this is
[ __ ] he steals the show is an amazing
[ __ ] shot of him sliding down a
building and [ __ ] that's fantastic I
think they're leaning into surfer bro
Aquaman so hard and I loved every minute
of it yes hey he's just like a bad I dig
it yes yes all of that all the time yeah
and also very a very no more take on
Aquaman certainly not the Aquaman of our
childhood he talks too fishy like go
caught you with a [ __ ] pitchfork you
fool on Ocean pitchfork also called the
Trident
um yeah man some wonderful stuff on
display on that trailer would you like
in the trailer I mean I I love
Commissioner Gordon
I just want grizzled and Greek
Commissioner Gordon all the time I still
don't know what the [ __ ] cyborg is doing
in this movie other than it was like
giver City hire but aren't I supposed to
say that [ __ ] I can get away with it
though man I got Rebecca race cards here
whipping him around I don't know I'll go
the other way I actually like his smooth
calm performance when he's like I'll
take it from here Alfred I'm kind of
looking forward to because the last time
we saw the first time we saw this kid
was his birth in like the Batman V
Superman [ __ ] stroke videos that he's
watching at one point in that movie
where you see him come alive it's a guys
in agony screaming so I like that
they've portrayed them as pretty damn
calm not robotic but pretty damn kind of
down here everything's right here and
well that's what you have to do if
you're a black guy nice we're moving
right lay it down take it down hey all
right wider I got your [ __ ] ban will
be laid him it's all good you'll have a
fine as long as you move and starring
Lou Rawls
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
you